I'm Matt Schwartz,
I was an MBA in Stanford's 2017 class and
I'm the co founder and CEO of Afresh.
>> And I'm Nathan Fenner,
MBA Class of 2017, and
I'm the co founder and
president of Afresh.
[MUSIC]
>> Around the world,
hundreds of billions of dollars of
fresh food are thrown away every year.
And that fresh food represents millions
and millions of tons of greenhouse
gases that are created both in
the landfills after they're thrown away.
And also in the energy that's used to
grow, distribute, produce, that food.
It's a really corny story that
Nathan hates when I share.
When I first met him,
it was at an adamant weekend to the GSB.
After spending a few days with Nathan,
I called my mom and
I told her I'm going to start
a company with this guy.
>> But
I think I chose building this company for
the opportunity to work with Matt,
I think Matt was frequently dismissed at
business school because he's so honest.
But I was just thoroughly impressed with
him, it's saw someone who I was really
kind of my counter point in terms of
my values and how I saw the world.
>> And the summer between our
years at the MBA program.
Nathan and I signed up for an independent
research study with a GSB lecturer in
which we did this big investigation
of the fresh food supply chain.
Talking to a bunch of businesses,
there was just an absolute
technology gap across the board.
And that in turn culminated in us
identifying the immediate opportunity for
Afresh.
>> A mentor once told me, look for
areas that are really
under-penetrated by technology.
Find that field where that initial
technological innovation really,
really moves the needle.
And so what we do as a company is
we've built the first of its kind
Fresh Food First supply chain
technology for the Fresh Food Industry.
>> Food more so than any other industry,
shapes the health of people and
our planet.
It'd be better around the world
if people ate more fresh food.
At the same time,
fresh food is really costly.
One of the biggest drivers of that cost
is the fact that so much of it is wasted.
With what we're doing at Afresh, we
prevented on an order of 10 million pounds
of cumulative food waste
reduction at this point.
I think the ability to go to work every
day knowing that every ounce of sweat that
we put in, has that positive impact, is
the thing that motivates us in the team.
[MUSIC]